you've seen the show hoers they collect
things like receipts MH napkins that
have been used yeah weird weird
dead rats but that's the worst
hoarders oh you think I'm Gateway I
think you're yeah you're maybe level
three four you know what I mean I I
think it's not even that he doesn't um
want to get rid of things he he just
doesn't know how to throw like he
doesn't know what a trash can looks like
physically I I I can tell you I that's
that's
crazy describe one describe because do
you remember green guy in um in
Sesame Street yeah's he lived in one
grouo grouo the
marks yeah yeah was what's his name I
want you to do this this is right so um
this is great podcast green right and
furry right gr his is Grouch but who the
Grouch uh give me the give me the first
letter give me the first letter give me
the first letter oh
op wow osar Oscar Oscar Oscar Oscar
the Oscar